catherine gravel a décidé s'envoler vers
le sud avec sa famille
oui s'échauffent et avec les voyages
cholin ça va bien depuis un mois le
téléphone a commencé à sonner dans les
agences de voyages après ça on va en
tout inclus
donc on arrive là bord on s'envoie mais
pour le sud
il y a beaucoup moins de vols
disponibles en ce moment dont environ 1
8 10 vols par semaine ou lui 80 donc on
auront 90 % moins d'offres par contre
les vols sont quasiment pleins les
voyagistes comme air canada où air
transat offre gratuitement une assurance
que vides
la couverture est de 200 mille dollars
et couvre les soins médicaux et le
transport ambulancier ou le rapatriement
si vous attrapez l'aco vide pendant
votre séjour
mais il ne s'agit pas d'une assurance
annulation si vous tombez malade avant
de partir en voyage promet de payer tous
les premiers de poule de la mort
certains pays comme cuba test des
voyageurs à l'entrée si le résultat est
positif
le gouvernement cubain impose une
quarantaine de 14 jours
on va devoir rester dans la chambre
d'hôtel dans la famille on me iront eux
mêmes nous apporter la nourriture et ça
reste pas des voyages des vacances aussi
agréable qu'on aurait aimé dans les
hôtels certaines pratiques ont changé
vous savez les familles du fait qu'on
voit dans les points qu ils sont changés
mais dense est un serveur qui prépare
les assiettes pour nous donc aucun
voyageur qui se penche par dessus
d'olive du fixe sur une retour il faudra
prévoir deux semaines de quarantaine ont
la quarantaine elle est très stricte on
peut pas aller à l'épicerie on peut pas
la pharmacie on peut même pas là
l'hôpital
donc c'est une quarantaine qu'on doit
rester à domicile une escapade au soleil
malgré les risques et en cas de problème
on ne doit pas s'attendre à l'aide du
gouvernement canadien pour rentrer à la
maison
si l'un sans maison de radio canada
montréal